we are all insecure some a little more
than others some a little less and
perhaps some are just better at working
around it while others wear it on their
sleeves nonetheless we are all insecure
we're all insecure about who we are
because none of us truly know who or
what that is we're all insecure about
our achievements or lack thereof because
we are wired to never feel like enough
is ever enough and we're all insecure
about life itself because it looms over
us with its apathetic bravado mocking
our ignorance to its mystery arguably
insecurity is in us all fully included
with the human condition
from an evolutionary standpoint the
state of insecurity is likely to be
essential it is what has kept us on our
toes throughout history forcing us to
remain on high alert safe from our
environmental conditions and those who
seek to defeat us and it is also to some
degree at the root of the motivation to
progress and achieve success in life to
attempt to impact the world and acquire
a sense of importance but then how can
we reduce our sense of insecurity if it
is so essentially a part of us on one
hand you are part of the collective
humanity and the quality of your life
experience is partially based on your
ability to contribute to its forward
movement to feel like you have a sense
of contribution outside of yourself but
simultaneously you are a uniquely
complex being with a meaningful
individual experience of life that you
should enjoy and appreciate without it
getting reduced by a constant need to
influence impress or
prove something and this is what we must
understand and gain agency over that as
humans we have a conflict in our nature
our experience of life is both
individual and collective but we can and
should reduce the effects of this
conflict
by becoming aware of it and setting
limitations for how much we let it
impose a sense of insecurity into our
life use insecurity to your advantage
use it to light the flame within you to
facilitate self-discipline and
proficiency so that you can do cool
things and impact the world in positive
ways so you can feel involved fulfilled
and plugged into the collective use
insecurity as this fuel but know and
remind yourself that that's all it is
that as an individual your obligation in
life is not solely to contribute to the
evolution of the collective but that as
a self-aware conscious individual it is
also to appreciate your own existence to
appreciate that against all odds you get
to experience the phenomenon of life as
your unique self and you need nothing
beyond that to revel in the beauty of it
all to extend beyond the foolishness of
draining insecurities and self-doubt
contribute and find fulfilment in
helping humanity push the massive
boulder of evolution forward but don't
forget that we don't even know where we
are pushing it or why we are pushing it
in the first place and that we are all a
little insecure about that but perhaps
by simply realizing this you might just
feel a little less insecure
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder